I did not have sexual relations with
that woman miss Lewinsky people have got
to know whether or not their presidents
a crook well I'm not across that means
allowing Americans who like their doctor
and like their health care plan to keep
their plan what do these statements have
in common well they were all made by
American presidents and they have all
rather famously been called lies but the
similarities really and they're now you
can call all three statements untrue but
lying requires an intent to deceive
which means you have to know what the
person who said it was actually thinking
and that's where things can get a bit
tricky take for example I am NOT a crook
Nixon said it and yet he was forced to
resign from office his successor even
pardoned him so was Nixon lying about
being a crook maybe but maybe not
he seems to have thought that crook was
synonymous with bad person and for him
setting up his own little dirty tricks
unit and covering up its existence was
not all that bad now take if you like
your health care plan you can keep it
when he was promoting Obama care Barack
Obama almost certainly thought that this
was true he was in fact scorned and
embarrassed when it turned out that many
people were forced to change their
coverage later in other words this looks
a lot more like a mistake and how about
I did not have sexual relations with
that woman miss Lewinsky here we can
brandish the big scarlet L for liar
Bill Clinton knew what he had done and
any ordinary person would consider that
sexual relations he knew what he was
saying was false and that's a lie
American politicians of course are
hardly unique when brexit ears campaign
in a big red bus the first half of that
famous slogan on the side was not quite
a lie but not quite true
we send 350 million pounds to the EU
each week well that was true but the UK
got back million
a pound each week - that was intended to
mislead and it did public figures of
course have always said things that
weren't true take Donald Trump he says
so many things that are so quickly it
easily proved untrue it looks almost
like he doesn't even care about the
truth
take for example when he said that
barack and michelle obama have a
ten-foot wall around their house in
washington they don't many people said
this was yet another lie by donald trump
but it's possible that this misses the
point that statements like this from
trump have a whole different purpose to
entertain to provoke or a route rather
than to say something literally true one
eminent philosopher has even given a
memorable label to this kind of talk
[ __ ] as distinct from a liar a
bullshitter doesn't even care about the
truth it's beside the point and if we
throw around the word
lie when we don't know the speaker state
of mind for sure then we're weakening
the word lie and its meaning it's better
to use other words like nonsense
exaggeration untruth or even just
[ __ ] using these exact terms will
only make it more effective when we
catch powerful people red-handed in a
true no doubt about it lot
[Music]